-I'm freaking out.
You're freaking out?
I'm freaking out.
-I'm getting a little emotional.
Look at you. Cover boy.
Hello! Hello! Hello!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What's that pose called?
-You know, I love that pose.
That pose is called --
What is it called?
-I was talking to a friend
just now, and he said it's
someone just pushed you
over the shoulder,
and you're like, "Whoa!"
I think that's what it is.
That's the full name.
-Let me see what this is.
This one's going like...
I think this one is called,
"Oh, you're not going to
spoil the end for me."
-Oh, yeah!
[ Laughter ]
"I haven't seen 'Mayor of
Easttown' episode five yet.
Don't tell me what happened."
-That's the spoiler one?
-That's the spoiler one.
-Congrats on "Saturday Night
Live" and everything.
You're doing such a great job.
This whole cast,
this whole season.
-Yes. Everybody.
-The writers and cast.
-And crew. Everybody.
-And crew for doing this.
I mean, honestly,
for pulling a show off
in general is just amazing.
You did something on the show
a couple weeks ago
that got a lot of
people's attention.
You played the iceberg.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The iceberg
that sank the "Titanic."
Where did the idea come from?
-This?
-Walk me through it.
-Okay.
It's such a crazy journey
because the head writer
of "SNL," one of the head
writers, Anna Drezen,
an old friend of mine
from college,
she texted me in February.
"Hey, maybe for
the April 10th show,
for the 'Titanic' anniversary,
you can play the iceberg
who sank the 'Titanic.'"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Yeah, cool. Maybe, sure."
And then I kind of raised
my eyebrow at her over text.
But then April rolls around
and then I text her,
"Hey, were you serious about
that iceberg idea?"
And she was like,
"I completely forgot about it.
Let's do it. Why not?"
And then the entire week
we did it, we just --
we're losing our minds
a little bit
'cause we kept looking at each
other and bursting out laughing,
like, on Saturday
at like 7:00 p.m.
as we were supposed to
turn in scripts.
We were like,
"What are we doing?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"This will never make it
on to TV.
Will people 'get it?'
Because there is just
so much going on here."
-The iceberg came on "Update"
to promote --
-His album.
-Yes.
He has a techno --
-It's a hyper-pop, EDM,
new disco fantasia.
-Sorry.
-So it's a lot of genres.
-Yes, a lot of genres in there.
And then just got upset.
-Got upset because he doesn't
want to be known for this thing
that happened in his past
and he actually feels
victimized by it.
We had a line in there
that was originally,
"Yes, I remember
that boat attack,"
which I think is the perfect --
that's what happened
when the "Titanic" sank.
The iceberg was attacked by
a boat.
-That's correct.
The iceberg did not move.
-No.
-Yeah.
It was the funniest thing.
I loved it, and then it was
trending on Twitter
for like the next three days.
-Oh, my God.
-And it was massive.
By the way, the Mother's Day
show, your mom was fantastic.
Please tell her I thought
she was so funny.
Mom, you were great.
-She was great.
-The Purell.
-Purell.
She could handle a prop bit.
-Was she nervous?
-She was very nervous.
She wouldn't tell me
she was nervous,
but everyone complimented her
in the studio.
Like, "You handled the props
great."
She's like the Carrot Top
and Gallagher of moms.
[ Laughter ]
-She really is.
-She is.
-Oh, my goodness.
That's so funny.
I remember my mom was
on the Mother's Day thing.
And she was so nervous.
She was freaking out,
and I remember at the beginning,
we did a monologue
with all the moms.
Everyone's there, you know, with
their moms or dads, you know.
And we're all standing around.
And I got something in my eye.
-[ Gasps ]
-If you ever want to see
a disaster, get something
in your eye when there's 30 moms
on stage.
[ Laughter ]
Because I go like --
Someone's going,
"Hold your lid out
and roll your eye back."
"Blow in it!"
"No, put water in it!"
"No, blowing will be fine."
Grabbing my head.
I was like,
"Okay, guys, hold on."
-That's beautiful to be
screamed at by that many moms.
-It was a fantastic Mother's Day
moment for me.
-Yeah.
-I follow you on Instagram,
by the way.
I follow @fayedunaway.
-@Fayedunaway is the handle,
yes.
-I just think
that's interesting.
-Yeah. It's interesting.
All I want is for Faye Dunaway,
the real Oscar-winning actress,
to, like, sue me or something.
[ Laughter ]
-Would you go to court?
-I would go to court.
I would get locked into, like,
the longest battle with her.
No, all I want is just --
-Talk to her.
A cease and desist or -- Yeah.
-She's watching. Faye.
-Faye? Faye Dunaway.
-Legendary.
-Legendary actress Faye Dunaway.
-Amazing, gorgeous.
-All I want is for you
to reach out to me
and call me
"that sniveling homosexual."
[ Laughter ]
-That's not what you want.
-Yes, it is what I want!
It is what I want!
Because she's fantastic
and I just want her
to insult me and say,
"You give that handle to me.
I want to be on Instagram
with everybody else."
-I don't think she would care
about Instagram,
but I think that she cares about
you and that you love her,
and I think that she would say,
"Hey, you know what?
You've got my blessing."
-Wow! I hope that happens.
-"And I love you and congrats on
your success, Bowen Yang."
-Jimmy, thanks so much
for having me.
-Dude, you're the greatest, bud.
I'm so happy for you, pal.
Bowen Yang.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The season finale of "Saturday
Night Live" airs this Saturday.